WINDOWS XP EAR-RAAAAAAPE
(bowser laugh or sumting)
satan plz
here kitty OHHHHHHH
no mor happy wheels videos
AGHHHHAGHH
i cant take it any more AHHHH ha ha
i cant take it any more
no
I WANNA DO HAPPY WHELLS
Oh Whats Dis Guts And Glory so theres a game that u proly havent herd of
its in pre alpha that mens im cool 4 playing it and you can succ it
CRAWLING IN MY SKIIIIIN
that was 2 far he posted sum stuff on redit it looks hilarous and
were gunna cheack it out
Movement arrow keys & w a s d OHHHH my lord
Cum on lil' timmy Was dat yo name ok we got-gotta get to da school BOIIIII
witch is in
OHH my GOD what the FUC#
didnt no dat was possible
ALRIGHT CMON TIMMY WE GOTTA GO FEST
OH OH OH SH@A  I DIDNT C IT
Alright here we go BACK FLIP *breacking leg*
OLY SH@T DAT WAS AWESOME
I GOT MOVES SUN NOW WE GOTTA JUMP OVER DIS
NNN YES JUST AS PLANNED BOYY
( JAWS THEME )
oh no OH NO OHHHHH OHHHH
WHAT THE HELL
TIMMY GOT ATTAC-DECAPITADED
Try dat agin OH SLOW JESUS FUC#ING CHRIST!!! HIS HEAD
We Gotta Get To The School Boy There It I-
EGHHHH
GO FAST
Slow motion press zee
OH look at dat
Woah *head choping*
DIS IS HARD MAN that wat she said CMON TIMMY is his name timmy it was somthing else Whatever
Come on.
Oh. NOOOO!!!
GODDD DAMMIT
YOU SHITTY-
I have the worst kid, it was all the
child's fault.
*Timmy's Voice* But daaad!
Shut up!
*Exciting Music* Okay... here we go.
To the top, baby!
Fuck!
OHHH, OHHHHO! OHH!
What? The sound!
Think I-uh cracked my leg. You'll pay for-
-this Timmy.
Look at the body! Are you okay back there, boy?
Oh! Well we got rid of him. *Pewds turns into a pig*
Now I can finally get handicapped
parking. This is great, this is great.
This is it. This is the moment we all
waited for. I waited 84 years to go.
Yeah! Wooohoo!
FUCK! Are you kidding me?
Oh, my child is with me.
that was anticlimactic.
-SURVIVE THE TURRETS-
Are you serious?
*Timmy's Voice* Dad, I don't think we should do this!
Don't be a fucking pussy, here we go boy.
Nevermind.
Really nailed it, real-- Oh my god
this can be crazy.
FUCK YOU, BITCH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
OHHH missed me! OHHH SHIT OH SHIT THEY'RE EVERYWHERE!
*Schubert - Ave Maria plays.*
*widowmaker ?!?*
*BOOM*
Ohhhh! *Laughs*
We gotta go slow.
here we go. I'm scared.
Ohh! Pfffff. *Laughs*
*Wilhelm Scream*
We ditched the bait.
Can't hit me. Nothing can--oh shit, oh that really hurt.
I think I broke my arm.
And finish!
*Victory Music*
Woo- Oh ha ha.
That's awesome! This game is so fun.
Just a nice family... home ride..
What the hell? Oh my god! They're every-- *Screams*
We're being attacked by seesaw-- oh!
No! No! Can't hit me, hit my child,
don't hit me.
*Scream sound* It's just my leg, don't need that to ride a bike.
That's why I have two of them.
*Timmy's Voice* Dad, what are you doin'?
Don't worry about it.
Doon't worry about it.
Hohoh! Oh! Oh!
What the hell man?! It was supposed to hit my child!
*Death Note Music* Ahhh! It hurts!
It hu... oh shit! Nailed it!
Now eat my leg, boy.
Ohh my god, it's going a little fast!
Oh there's turrets, there's freaking
turrets - Backflip!
Oh my god, that was the coolest trick
ever. If only your mom saw that. Nice!
I call that one break my leg and sho... fuck,  and kill my child!
I'm genuinely enjoying playing this game.
It's really fun- *Laughs*
Oh god, oh god, I just got-- Ohhhh you
got shot in the head Timmy! Yeah!
*Victory Music*
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
Fuck my life.
Ah fuck's sake, not these.
Ahh! Son of a bitch!
Stop!
Oh! *Laughs*
Oh shit, fuck! *Laughs*
*Explodes*
Oh there's mines! Oh my god, there's mines everywhere.
That's okay.
Ahhhh, SPPPEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEED!!!
I'm scared. SPEEEEEEDDDD!!!!!!!
Oh god, there's mines everywhere! There's
mines everywhere.
Jesus, NOO! *Laughs*
We can make i-- Ohhh!
Fuck you, Jimmy!
*Victory Music* Yeah!
Suck it Jimmy, suck it!
We got the crazy maps now, fucking hell dude.
There's mines everywhere and Jimmy is gone,
My only shield of defense is gone. I got
an arrow through my genitalia and...
Oh shit that's gonna hurt tomorrow.
WOOO!!!
We are FINE, everything's FINE!
I could actually do this.
Frontflip.
That was awesome!
*Victory Music* Fuck yeah!
I took the flag with me.
Ok, that's all "Guts and Glory" has
to offer right now, it looks like a very -
promising game. Remember, this is Pre-Alpha. It's a very early.. game. If you're -
interested about the game, I'm gonna
leave us a link in the description, -
really cool stuff and if you enjoyed
this video,  please do leave a like and -
I'll see you bros in the next one, as
always, *kisses fist*
*Sucks in air" Stay awesome bros! *Brofist*
8==================D